les graphes des tanneries une dernière
fois mise en lumière par les lampes
torches des pompiers c'est au fond de ce
grand bâtiment désaffecté dans une
travée de 600 mètres carrés remplie
d'objets en tout genre que le feu a pris
vers 20h stockage important potentiel
calorifique important avec we différents
différents éléments qui pourraient
occasionner un risque plus important
comme des bouteilles de gaz comme
différents contenants avec de l'huile
avec éventuellement des solvants des
peintures et on retrouve on retrouve
même une cuve à fuel le tout dans un
bâtiment vétuste fait de plaques de
fibrociment et d'une structure
métallique
conscient du risque les pompiers
parviennent à éteindre les flammes
rapidement
au total environ 600 mètres cubes de
matériel ont brûlé provoquant le
dégagement d'une épaisse fumée noire qui
a alerté le voisinage
une fumée qu'il a fallu évacuer à l'aide
d'un ventilateur hydraulique
l'intervention a mobilisé sept véhicules
et une vingtaine de pompiers
elle s'est achevée à 23 heures la
circulation a été coupée boulevard de
chicago
les tanneries ses anciens abattoirs
squat est devenu un espace autogéré en
1998 avec une salle de concert sont à
l'abandon depuis quelques mois la mairie
de dijon a le projet de construire ici
un écoquartier et après de longues
négociations le collectif qui était
installée à accepter de déménager dans
de nouveaux locaux
la destruction du grand bâtiment a donc
débuté fin mai et ce sont les
entreprises en charge du chantier qui
procéderont au déblaiement des gravats
suite à cet incendie